the boogeyman is back it really is an
adrenaline ride from start to finish
this Friday John wake chapter three
Parabellum is out in theaters and in
case you missed the first two chapters
of the franchise here's everything you
need to know before you go back in 2014
the first chapter the John wick series
became an instant cult classic I think
people like rooting for John wick to
kick everybody's ass in anywhere anytime
there's a vulnerability to him that's
always kind of driving what he's doing
at least from the point that we first
meet him in Frisco in a typical action
thriller the death of a spouse would set
off a vengeful killing spree but in the
case of John wick a fatal illness is
what rips his wife from his world and a
cute puppy and an unexpected twist is
the catalyst to unleash quick fury upon
his enemies a dead wife and a puppy
and losing his car three things a man
could not do it out in 2017 the sequel
continued the story by introducing John
Wiggs debt to Italian crime lord Antonia
D Antonio help John accomplish the
impossible task to leave their world of
violence behind in order to be with his
now deceased wife what is this mmm-hmm
do you remember this is your blood she
came to me I helped you and the debt he
repaid came with major repercussions I
want you to kill my sister you want me
to kill Gianna Dantonio it can't be done
to this for me
no Marc Rizzo
[Music]
out of my way rules were broken after
the death of D Antonio's sister what is
this he completed the task the Mokka is
over in order to distance himself from
the murder of Gianna Santino D Antonio
put a bounty on John wick for five
million dollars and they know what kind
of man will they be
that means that any assassin who takes
out the boogeyman will receive the large
reward
chapter three Parabellum picks up after
the bounty on John wick has been raised
from five million to 14 million mr. Witt
broke the rules John wick is this super
assassin who is you know the baddest guy
in town and all of the other badass
assassins in the world are after him
[Music]
and so how does he deal with that who
are the characters how do they help or
hinder his ability to stay alive
Chadd at the helm and Keanu with all of
his preparation and training they
brought it they brought it yeah his
vision will be here and I have to I'm
really the limit we just thought Canton
with a really bitchin on a horse and I
but we both loved westerns so I thought
that would be really fun for me it's
great to try and aspire to to that
vision it looks like we can expect
heightened action sequences with swords
on motorcycles and a combat on horseback
there's a sequence in there for the
knife fight which was probably the most
physically intensive John we can take
you a certain direction through our
world but it'd be nice to have other
characters to take you to different
routes when I speak to people about it
they love the world they love the world
of the Continental the characters that
inhabit the world you know you might
have think we've met in the film if we
have on the phone to each other and you
talk a lot but we actually and you
understand our relationship with John
which is he's our favorite assassin and
we'll break the rules for him a little
bit more than anyone else our services
still off-limits
what do you need since chapter three is
giving us even more depth into wix
underworld will be learning about their
relationships between the key players
and more assassins will be introduced
you get bigger better more beautiful
with the addition of you know to grow
anjelica huston anjelica huston plays
the director a high-ranking member of
the high table Delma too
I can't help you
Asia K Dylan has the educator another
high-ranking member of the high table
the new major assassins we meet are
played by Mark Dacascos you haven't
disappointed Jerome Flynn and Halle
Berry another good addition to it you
shouldn't be here
nice good to see you too I was a fan of
1 & 2 and I just heard that Chad was
doing 3 and he was looking for a female
character that was kind of badass and I
thought well let me go meet you at the
most physically challenging thing I've
ever done in my career for sure and
laurence fishburne returns the Bowery
King a crime lord that rules a territory
in lower Manhattan we were first
introduced to the Barry King in chapter
2 and that rounds up the Matrix trilogy
reunion all of this for what because of
a puppy my children I know thank you Dex
whatever it takes
yeah wasn't just a puppy
[Music]
so now you know and now you can go see
John wick three opening and theaters on
Friday May 17 make sure that you have
some time to rest afterwards
you